from one of its Warehouse units staff
with comeback alive processed the latest
shipments of gear needed by soldiers on
the front lines as Ukraine's biggest
private volunteering group it has
collected and spent hundreds of millions
of dollars since the start of the
fullscale war nearly 2 years ago now
along with all other organizations it
will have to follow new government
regulations aimed at making volunteering
and donating more
accountable people were taking advantage
of the system Aid and military gear
wasn't being tracked and we didn't know
if it was ending up in the right
hands the government is centralizing the
system for processing and tracking
different types of Aid with volunteering
groups and individuals required to
register formally it's seen as being
part of Ukraine's overall effort to
become more transparent ahead of
possible European union and NATO
membership but since the start of the
war a vast number of smaller voluntary
groups have sprung into being that don't
have the resources of bigger
organizations yes larger groups have
lots of stuff who can handle these
issues they get a salary for this it's
their job we don't have these people
smaller groups like this one say the new
requirements will make the delivery of
Aid harder and
slower I have not had AO for a year and
a half when I come home in the evening I
start my volunteering work and most of
us work every weekend we don't have time
for this extra bureaucracy and for these
volunteers questions about EU membership
are meaningless without victory on the
front lines Rob McBride Al jazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer